des offres promotionnelles
oui pourquoi pas des remboursements sous
48 heures c'est la moindre des choses
vous pensez vraiment que c'est ça une
mutuelle qui va bien la mutuelle les
ménages prévoyant l
elle protège ses adhérents depuis plus
de 160 ans une mutuelle qui garantit une
telle longévité
c'est ça une mutuelle qui va bien
cliquez pour voir
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
premier numéro de check up votre
magazine santé et bien-être
au programme de cette édition d auto
test vih arrive en pharmacie nous allons
voir comment il fonctionne le centre
hospitalier de versailles a créé un
fonds de dotation
nous verrons pourquoi l'hôpital a besoin
de soutien les travaux de l'institut
marcel rivière de la verrière vont
bientôt commencer
la mgen a présenté le futur chantier la
mutuelle des ménages prévoyant a fêté
ses cent soixante ans d'existence
focus sur l'une des plus anciennes
mutuelles de france et enfin pour la
journée mondiale d'alzheimer des
personnalités se mobilisent autour de
lectures pour sensibiliser à la maladie
et pour commencer les autres tests vih
ont fait leur apparition en pharmacie
des tests à faire soi même qui
permettent à chacun de savoir si les
porteurs du virus du sida
élaboré par la société a à z ce qui
apparaît comme un nouvel outil
permettant de favoriser le dépistage en
france on regarde tout de suite un
reportage sur des images d'elodie mois
avec une goutte de sang en fait on met
une de 200 on l'appliqué 15 minutes
après chili à deux bandes
en fait c'est positif une bande c'est
négatif
l'auto test du vih est donc aujourd'hui
possible depuis le 15 septembre des
autotests sont disponibles en pharmacie
sous la forme d'un kit un nouvel outil
qui permet un anonymat complet mais qui
pose aussi la question de la solitude
face à la maladie en cas de résultat
positif le test doit être confirmée par
un dépistage classique en laboratoire la
fiabilité est proche effectivement donc
des 100% 99,9
quoi qu'il en soit c'est important de
rappeler que le délai est un délai donc
de trois mois après une prise de risque
malgré un coût élevé 25 euros en moyenne
non remboursés par l'assurance maladie
ce kit devrait s'adresser à un public
moins réceptifs aux outils classiques de
prévention vous avez aujourd'hui des
gens qui parfois toute leur famille ou
des femmes qui trompent le donc leur
leurs amis leurs conjoints et pour le
coup ils n'ont pas forcément la
possibilité d'aller en centre de
dépistage parce que parfois les horaires
sont un peu compliquées ils sont
effectivement donc en train de
travailler et là pour le coup c'est
compliqué d'aller voir son médecin
généraliste en dix ans j'aimerais bien
faire un test du sida des autotests
devrait être gracieusement mis à
disposition des associations afin
d'atteindre les personnes des plus
arides
éloigné du dépistage en france ce sont
trente mille personnes qui ignorent
encore leur séropositivité autre auto
test est négatif
le centre hospitalier de versailles a
lancé la création d'un fonds de dotation
l'hôpital qui a vu son activité croître
ces dernières années a besoin d'un
soutien financier supplémentaire pour
pourvoir à la modernisation des
équipements mais aussi au développement
de la recherche
reportage d'anciennes prothèse
reconverti en oeuvre d'art si michel a
pour habitude de réaliser ses sculptures
pour le plaisir cette fois ci il le fait
à contribution de l'hôpital c'est un peu
comme une boucle ce petit clin d'oeil
qui part justement de l'est fait que les
pièces sont recyclés et que l'argent de
le bénéfice de cette vente reviendra
automatiquement fonds de dotation un
fonds de dotation pour le centre
hospitalier de versailles l'hôpital
lance un appel au mécénat pour soutenir
l'établissement conférences concerts et
vente aux enchères ont ponctué le
week-end de lancement pour récolter des
fonds
l'objectif de réduction des déficits des
comptes publics a amené le gouvernement
à demander aux établissements de santé
réduire leurs charges et cette réduction
de charges elle s'est traduite pour le
moment par une diminution des tarifs
pour les hôpitaux une diminution
tarifaire qui représente une perte de 2
millions d'euros sur l'année 2015 pour
le fonds de dotation trois objectifs ont
été fixés
l'amélioration des conditions de vie des
patients le développement de la
recherche et la modernisation des
équipements ça va aussi bien d'une gamma
caméra en médecine nucléaire ou d'une
irm dont qui sont de très gros
équipements qui valent plusieurs
millions d'euros avec l'ouverture de
nouveaux services comme celui de la
médecine nucléaire inauguré il ya trois
mois mais aussi une forte augmentation
du recours aux services des urgences
la direction de l'hôpital s'est fixé
l'objectif de 200 mille euros de levée
de fonds annuelle des dons défiscalisés
hauteur de 60% pour les entreprises et
66 % pour les particuliers et pour
continuer ce magazine check-up
l'institut mgen de la verrière va
bientôt faire peau neuve
les équipes ont présenté le projet de
reconstruction qui commencera début 2016
l'établissement prendra en charge des
patients de la préadolescence aux
personnes âgées on regarde un reportage
de mélanie poker c'est à ça que
ressemble ras le nouvel institut sur le
site marcel rivière
il regroupera les patients des centres
denis forestier centre gériatrique créée
en 1974 et marcel rivière établissements
de santé mentale construit en 1959
la plupart des pavillons d'habitation
n'ont pas évolué depuis cette année
l'année 1959 donc oui il y avait un
besoin en santé mentale
en ce qui concerne le bâtiment l'autre
hôpital denis forestier la médecine
court séjour ils soins de suite les
besoins auraient pu attendre encore
quelque temps mais des raisons
d'efficience économique ont fait
ensemble par une seule fois les
bâtiments actuels d'une capacité de 409
lits seront détruits pour faire place au
futur établissement
à l'ouverture le futur institut contre à
4 185 lits et 45 place pendant les
travaux le site gériatrique de denis
forestier n'est pas touché par les
travaux il fonctionne de la même manière
par contre là si tu marchais la rivière
voit une diminution partielle de ce
nombre de lits de psychiatrie
durant ses pairs des travaux puisque
nous construisons comme l'on dit en site
occupé le centre se structurera en
quatre pôles cliniques pour prendre en
charge les patients de la préadolescence
aux personnes âgées
des travaux qui vont aussi concerner la
population vers hyéroise et alentours on
a beaucoup discuté que les jeunes sur
l'originalité finalement de la conduite
du chantier et on veut un chantier
environnemental de grande qualité
et puis que les jeunes entreprises de
l'économie sociale et solidaire
s'implique avec l'entreprise dans
différentes clauses faire travailler des
sous-traitants locaux former des jeunes
privilégier l'emploi local et
d'information aux représentants
l'investissement de plus de 100 millions
d'euros
le nouvel institut devrait voir le jour
en 2010 9 les démolition des bâtiments
actuels commenceront en mars 2016 une
autre mutuelle maintenant celle des
ménages prévoyants qui vient de fêter
ses cent soixante ans d'existence cette
mutuelle créée en 1854 compte
aujourd'hui plus de soixante mille
adhérents précurseur à l'époque cet
outil de solidarité s'est peu à peu
ouverts à toutes les couches sociales
pour devenir la mutuelle d'aujourd'hui
on regarde un reportage sur des images
de david charpentier les ménages
prévoyant une mutuelle qui perdure créée
en 1854 par le baron caruhel de saint
martin la lmp fêté le 17 septembre à
versailles c'est cent soixante années
d'existence
aux origines la lmp permettait à ses
sociétaires de bénéficier d'un accès
gratuit aux soins
puis elle s'est développée en accord
avec l'évolution des besoins sociaux
alors peut-être se soigner d'avoir des
médicaments première mutuelle à accepter
les femmes comme sociétaire la lmp signe
en 1955 un contrat d'entreprise avec le
site renault de flins
une stratégie qui lui permettra de
passer de 1000 sociétaires en 1945 à
plus de 60000 dans les années 2000 à la
norme solvabilité ii européenne qui va
nous imposer habilité supplémentaires
donc ça c'est vraiment un grand défi à
relever parce que 1er janvier 2016 qui
seront soumis aux mêmes règles que les
grandes sociétés d'assurances en 2016
les nouvelles règles législatives
européennes impacteront tous les
organismes d'assurance
un nouveau défi pour la mutuelle
notamment avec les nouvelles règles de
gouvernance dans le cadre de la journée
mondiale d'alzheimer et pour mobiliser
le grand public et soutenir les malades
et leurs proches l'association france
alzheimer a lancé sa campagne des mots
pour alzheimer des personnalités ont
prêté leur voix aux malades et à leurs
familles
on regarde une lecture d'yves duteil
mais ça va bien riche et rare tu n'as
rien cette phrase si vous saviez combien
de fois je n'ai entendu il faut dire que
jamais que cinquante cinq ans et puis
j'aime rire et plaisanter je refuse
d'adopter une mine de circonstance pour
qu'on s'apitoie sur mon sort car je
pense que ça aggraverait encore ma
maladie alors forcément les gens ne
voient pas ne savent pas ils ne peuvent
même pas imaginer ce que je vis ma
mémoire s'évapore comme des effluves
d'alcool
j'ai perdu la notion du temps je peux
rester des heures dans un magasin sans
m'en rendre compte
j'ai beaucoup de mal à me concentrer
aussi et je suis incapable de planifier
une journée car le moment venu
j'oublierai plus de la moitié des choses
à faire même celles marquées en évidence
sur une feuille sous mon nez et aussi
cette pression comme une grande fatigue
dans la tête qui ne me quitte jamais
c'est comme après une nuit blanche
sauf que pour moi c'est tous les jours
du matin jusqu'au soir
mais le plus insupportable je crois
c'est ce qu'on appelle le défaut
d'exécution vouloir faire quelque chose
même de très simple et ne pas pouvoir
l'exécuter parce que les gestes ne
suivent pas la pensée c'est très dur à
accepter
je ne peux rien faire tout seul j'ai
besoin de ma femme pour tout comme j'ai
de la chance qu'elle soit là elle est
mon amour mon bien-être
ma volonté
alors oui mon apparence jeunesse cash
l'envers du décor et je fais beaucoup
d'efforts à l'extérieur de chez moi pour
que personne ne remarque mes difficultés
que personne ne remarque que je ne peux
ni m'habiller tout seul ni ouvrir un
placard ni même aller chercher un verre
d'eau aujourd'hui j'aimerais donc dire
aux gens qu'ils peuvent un jour me
croiser non je ne suis pas un
extraterrestre
et oui je suis malade ne veut discuter
plus quand je gare ma voiture sur une
place handicapée et que j'en ressors en
sifflotant
je n'ai pas volé mon macaron coller sur
mon pare-brise
je suis handicapé à 80%
même si ça ne se voit pas
passons maintenant à l'agenda de dates à
retenir du 12 au 23 octobre au centre
culturel michel luxure aux deux trappes
aura lieu la quinzaine de la nutrition
et de la santé
expositions débats et ateliers
ponctueront ces deux semaines placées
sous le signe de l' équilibre
alimentaire
et puis à la pmi de la verrière tous les
mercredis sont organisées des rencontres
avec un orthophoniste pour répondre à
vos questions sur le développement du
langage de l'enfant et pour terminer ce
magazine un bon plan l'application tube
peu lancé par hachette prévention
répertorie sur votre smartphone les
différents points de vente de
préservatifs ainsi que les centres de
dépistage autour de vous un outil de
prévention qui donne également des
conseils pratiques sur les différents
thèmes st voilà c'est terminé pour ce
premier magazine de check up je vous
donne rendez-vous dans deux semaines
pour un prochain numéro
et d'ici là prenez soin de vous